what does joe need joe needs oh  death death people tweet you this stuff  like want you to kidnap me do they say  that in real life are people coming up  to you please keep it no people come up  to me in shackles like just take me i'm  ready i've done the hard work  the cage is back there just put me in  fully aware that joel goldberg is [ __ ]  up and creepy and not good capital ng  but why did they get such a pretty man  to play him i  you know why they did it we all know why  they did it if i tweet something and it  doesn't sound like me at all y'all  better start dialing 9-1-1 because it's  joe and i'm in the basement of his  library hashtag you on netflix you  netflix hashtag you he took away your  phone you wouldn't be able to tweet